in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Ryan
and Molly join us hey guys how are you
doing welcome welcome Merry Christmas
how are you doing good to have you guys
so where do you live
Nashville Tennessee welcome so we're
neighbors then very cool I'm here to do
your debt free screaming person
absolutely I love it how much have you
paid off we've paid off three hundred
and thirty six thousand dollars
Wow full in nine and a half years nine
years eight months to be exact way to go
that must be your house and everything
no no okay well come back and hear the
story not much is your what your
household income currently we're about
140 uh-huh we started out forty five and
then we've each I got a job and and then
we both had incremental increases in our
income and then Molly has since gone
part-time so its fluctuated a lot of it
during the course of this time yeah what
in the world what kind of debt is this
was it school all school loans well
about 98 percent yeah uh-huh so we both
went to undergraduate school had both
small loans from undergraduate school
and then we decided we would go to
graduate school and what better way to
do it but to just jump in with Sallie
Mae and because that's the smart thing
to do and kind of that's we didn't know
any better so that's what we did so you
both have graduate degrees yes sir and
what Masters of Nursing mm-hmm we're
both nurse practitioners okay excellent
okay so deeply in debt and the maximum
income through this period of time was
one hundred and forty yes sir Wow okay
and you clawed and scratched your way
out over nine and a half years tell me
the story what happened well in 2005
we've been married a year and a half we
bought a home it was we were now
graduated from school and it was
everything was kind of just coming all
in at once and we realized I've had a
come-to-jesus meeting with myself at
home while Molly was out of town when
weekend and I just felt overwhelmed by
the sense of burden and what I've gotten
myself into as a young man and just
starting out my career so we sat down in
October of 2005
shared the unfortunate information that
I had kind of calculated with her and we
were both scared we were both real
overwhelmed no it's a lot of money yeah
and we just decided you know what we're
just going to try to just start one step
at a time of this thing and in doing
that we just started taking baby steps
and never do we ever feel like a gazelle
felt more like a turtle however we just
kind of just kept kept doing what we
were doing and just kind of stayed with
it and for the first few years that we
were doing things we would look at the
balance sheet at the end of the year we
had paid off a lot of money but hey you
have words paying off thirty five
thousand a year yeah not at first and it
just the needle wasn't moving
um but we kept kept doing things and we
just kept our lifestyle where it is and
didn't kind of do what we wanted to do
was just kind of go and live life so and
started making a little bit of progress
and then I believe at that point
probably maybe halfway through the thing
there's there started to be a sense of
hope it started changing um we started
seeing the needle move well enough that
said you know what we look at one
another inside of you know I think we
actually could take it to the end
because it's just going to work for the
longest time it was let's let's make a
dent and that's big enough that when we
get ready to have children our we get
ready to move into a new home it would
be feasible but there was not this
conceived notion that we could actually
take it to the end yeah and it was six
or seven years into it 2011 end of 2011
we said you know what this actually
looks like it could be having into it we
could actually count the number of years
on our hands that we had to at the end
and then in 2012 and our small group
through our church we had so family that
sponsored our FPU class we've been doing
these principles and paying off debt for
years but we had never formally done the
materials so we did FPU in 2012 and 2012
was already we were on track to do
really well and that was just a huge
shot in the arm it kind of just took us
up to a whole new level so 2012
2013 in 2014 were probably our best
years where we were just able to see the
light and really the sacrifices we had
made over the years thus far we were
actually seeing them come to fruition
and know that there was in and I was
really pretty quite amazing Molly this
is nine and a half years mm-hmm
how do you feel like you got stuck it
out don't make me cry on air I it our
marriage grew much stronger through this
and I I really I give all the credit to
Ryan Ryan has been a saver his whole
life so for him to look up and see he
was in this much debt and then to just
have the steadfastness to lead us we
would have a lot of budget meetings and
I would just say I can't handle look in
these numbers and get up and walk away
and it was you know we just kept at it
is all you know and kept discussing how
hard it was and how worth it it would be
yeah I've read this book The Tortoise
and the hare and every time I read the
book The Tortoise wins you want you want
and they cannot can I add during this
time we we cash flowed for babies oh
there's that yeah yeah no step for a
stepper right things I mean yeah I mean
naught and a half years life yeah
there's a lot of life happens in that
period of time especially young marrieds
and so forth and so very very cool so it
must feel like you've lost a thousand
pounds it's surreal actually it's it's
surreal because we had developed a
behavioral and just a lifestyle that we
just were used to saying no to things
and and that was okay because we knew we
were doing the right thing but it still
was difficult and it was just kind of
but what we had kind of got used to
hearing and doing and and just knowing
we were coming to the end it felt good
but actually when we were at the end
it fell in crowd now when did you pay
the last payment July the 1st 2015 okay
just the other day about four five six
months ago now I guess I lost
well how months ago and so you paid by
computer actually so we had a little bit
our story is a little bit different so
at the end we had a family inheritance
of a small bit of money that was able to
just push us over the edge yeah we had
about three years left and I feel like
at that very end it was just felt like
God just kind of went enough yeah enough
yeah well done yeah and and we were able
to so in the end when we did pay it off
we were able to make a lump sum payment
so we went out to dinner we were going
to do it we're going to celebrate we
were going to you know call up Sallie
Mae and of course they weren't prepared
to take a lump sum of cash over the
phone and it was technical and all these
different things so it totally rained on
our parade on the 30th of June messed up
the dinner so they actually get someone
they're not even competent to take a
payment that's the gospel with those
people yeah it was quite an intriguing
conversation oh yeah yeah they hear them
on their line and that's where you get
people on the line their parents or
cousins man I mean it's unbelievable
just yeah well congratulations and all
throughout this whole process
Ryan he'd pull in from work and I'd hear
you on his radio and we just said we're
gonna do it we're gonna scream when this
is over you are and we have a lot of
really fun people here to celebrate with
good I know you brought your friends and
family and stuff that's the way it
should be
and here we are at Christmastime - so
fresh start next year
whole new life ahead of you and you guys
know you need to know that if you can do
this you can do anything this is amazing
I mean you looked at that mountain and
said move and it did and so these
youngsters with you here for little
girls that's it for little girls Oh wine
on the way and one on the way alright
alright so three hundred and thirty six
thousand dollars paid off in nine and a
half years making forty five up to 140
Wow Ryan and Molly Elise Annie Margaret
and Evelyn count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one
nine years oh man
it's amazing you guys are awesome this
is the Dave Ramsey show you guys would
be so rich so fast and be able to do so
much not only for yourselves and for
your family but for others
you